in the last video we learned or at least
i showed you i don't know if you've
learned it yet but we'll learn in this
video but we learned that the force on a
moving charge
from a magnetic field and it's a vector
quantity is equal to the charge
on the moving charge
times the cross product of the velocity
of the charge
and the magnetic field
and we use this to show you that the
units of
a magnetic field this is not this is not
a beta it's a b
the units of a magnetic field are the
tesla which is uh which is abbreviated
with a capital t and that is equal to
newton's
seconds
per coulomb
meters so let's see if we can apply that
to an actual problem
so let's say that i have
a magnetic field and let's say it's
popping out of the screen i'm making
this up on the fly so i hope the numbers
turn out it's inspired by a problem that
i read in baron's ap calculus book
so if i want to draw a a bunch of
vectors or vector field that's popping
out of the screen i could just do the
top of the arrow heads i'll draw them in
magenta
so let's say i have a vector field
so you can imagine a bunch of arrows
popping out of the screen
i'll just draw a couple of them
just so you get the sense that it's a
field it pervades the space
so these are a bunch of arrows popping
out and these and and the field
is popping out and the magnitude of the
field let's say it is
i don't know let's say it is point
five
teslas
let's say i have some proton that comes
speeding along
i have some proton that comes speeding
along
and it's speeding along
at a velocity
so the velocity of the proton
is equal to
6
times 10 to the seventh
meters per second and that is actually
about a fifth the the velocity or a
fifth of the speed of light so this is a
you know we're almost we're pretty much
in the relativistic realm but we won't
go too much into relativity because then
the mass of the proton increases et
cetera et cetera we just assumed that
the mass hasn't increased significantly
at this point so we have this proton
going at a fifth of the speed of light
and it's crossing through this magnetic
field so the first question is what is
the magnitude and direction of the force
on this proton from this magnetic field
well let's figure out the magnitude
first
so how can we figure out the magnitude
well the cross product well first of all
what is the charge on a proton
well we don't know it right now but my
calculator has that stored and if you
have a ti graphing calculator your
calculator will also have it stored in
it so let's just write that down as a
variable right now
so the magnitude of the force
on the particle
is going to be equal to
the charge of a proton
i'll call it q sub p
times the magnitude of the velocity
6 times
10 to the seventh meters per second
we're using all the right units if this
was centimeters we'd probably want to
convert it to meters
6 times 10 to the 7th meters per second
and then times
times the magnitude of the magnetic
field which is 0.5
teslas i didn't have to write the units
there but i'll do it there times sine of
the angle between them
right i'll write that down right now
sine of the angle between them but let
me ask you a question
if the magnetic field is pointing
straight out of the screen
and you're going to have to do a little
bit of three-dimensional visualization
now
and this particle is moving in the plane
of the field what is the angle between
them
if you visualize it in three dimensions
they're actually
they're orthogonal to each other they're
at right angles to each other right
because these vectors are popping out of
the screen they are perpendicular to the
plane that defines the screen right
while this proton is moving within this
plane so so the angle between them if
you can visualize it in three dimensions
is 90 degrees or they are perfectly
perpendicular and when things are
perfectly perpendicular what is the sine
of 90 degrees or the sine of pi over 2
either way if you want to deal in
radians well it's just equal to 1 right
the whole the whole
hopefully intuition you got about the
cross product is we only want to
multiply the components of the two
vectors that are perpendicular to each
other and that's why we have the sine of
theta but if the entire vectors are
perpendicular to each other then we just
multiply the magnitude of the vector or
if you even forget to do that you say oh
well they're perpendicular they're at 90
degree angles sine of 90 degrees well
that's just 1.
so this is just 1.
so the magnitude of this of of the force
is actually pretty easy to calculate if
we know that the charge on a proton
let's see if we can figure out the
charge on a proton
let me get the trusty ti-85 out
and actually i i well let me clear there
just so you can
appreciate
that
t85 store so if you press second and
constant that second and then the number
four that little constant above it
you get their constant functions
or their values and you say the built-in
i care about the built-in function so
let me press f1
and they have a bunch of you know this
is avogado's number and they have a
bunch of you know a bunch of interesting
this is the charge of an electron which
is actually the same thing as the charge
of a proton so let's use that
right electrons just remember electrons
and protons have offsetting charges once
positive one's negative
it's just that a proton is more massive
that's how they're different and of
course it's positive so let's just
confirm that that's the charge of a
electron
yep that looks about right but that's
also the charge of a proton and actually
this positive value is the exact charge
of a proton they should have maybe put a
negative number here but all we care
about is the value so let's use
that again the charge of electron and it
is positive so that's the same thing as
the charge of a proton
times
6
times 10 to the seventh 6e7 is just you
just press that ee button on your
calculator times 0.5 teslas
times 0.5 teslas make sure all your
units are in tesla's meters
and coulombs and then your result will
be in newtons
and you get
4.8 times 10 to the negative
12 newtons
let me write that down so the magnitude
of this force
right that was the magnitude the
magnitude of this force is equal to 4.8
times 10
to the minus 12
newtons so that's the magnitude now what
is the direction
what is the direction of this force well
this is where we break out our we put
our pens down if we're right handed and
we we
use our right hand rule to figure out
the direction so what do we have to do
so when you take something across
something
the first thing in the cross product is
your index finger on your right hand
right so let's see if i and then the
second thing
is your your middle finger pointed at a
right angle with your index finger so
let's see if i could do this so i want
my
i want my index finger on my right hand
to point to the right
but i want my middle finger to point
upwards so let me see if i can pull that
off
let me see if i can pull that off so my
right hand is going to look something
like this
and my hand is brown
so
so my right hand is going to look
something like this my index finger
is pointing in the in the direction of
the velocity vector
while my middle finger is pointing the
direction of the magnetic field so my
index finger is going to point straight
up
so all you see is the tip of it and then
my other fingers are just going to go
like that
and then my thumb is going to do what my
thumb is going i have you know this is
the heel of my thumb
and so my thumb is going to be the right
angle to both of them so my thumb points
down like this
this is often the hardest part just
making sure you get your hand visually
visualization right with the cross
product
so just as a review this is
the direction of v
this is the direction of the the
magnetic field right it's popping out
and so if i arrange my right hand like
that my thumb points down
so this is the direction of the force so
as
this particle moves to the right with
some velocity there's actually going to
be a downward force
especially downward on this plane
so the force is going to move in this
direction
and so what's going to happen
well what happens if you remember a
little bit about your circular motion
and your centripetal acceleration all of
that what happens when you have a force
perpendicular to velocity
well think about if you have a force
here and the velocity is like that if
the particles it'll be deflected a
little bit to the right and then
since the force is always going to be
perpendicular to the velocity vector the
force is going to charge like that so
the particle is actually going to go in
a circle
right as long as it's in the magnetic
field
the force applied to the particle
by the magnetic field is going to be
perpendicular to the velocity of the
particle so the
so the velocity of the particle so it's
going to actually be like a centripetal
force on the particle so the particle is
going to go into a circle
and in the next video we'll actually
figure out the radius of that circle and
just one thing i want to think let you
think about it it's kind of i mean i
don't know it's it's kind of
weird or spooky to me that
that the force on a moving particle
it doesn't matter about the particle's
mass it doesn't
it just matters the particle's velocity
and charge so it's kind of a strange
phenomenon that the faster you move
through a magnetic field or at least if
you're charged if you're a charged
particle the faster you move through a
magnetic field the more force that
magnetic field is going to apply to you
it seems a little bit you know how does
that magnetic field know how fast you're
moving but anyway i'll leave you with
that in the next video we'll explore
this this magnetic phenomenon a little
bit deeper see you soon